[Музика]
Привіт усім і ласкаво просимо на
урок англійської, мене звати Ілана, і
сьогодні у нас другий урок на тему
науки і техніки, а тема
нашого сьогоднішнього уроку полягає в тому, наскільки ви володієте технікою
, звертайте увагу на  word tech savvy
tech savvy definitional it colony
ви технічні підковані комплекти, тоді цей урок
для вас, тому що сьогодні ми вивчаємо
технічні слова, але для початку давайте
подумаємо про те, що ми знаємо і як ми
насправді технічні, скажемо, якщо ми заглянемо
туди  12 чисел і 12 питань
за ними, яке улюблене число, з
якого питання ми повинні почати,
нехай це буде число вісім, давайте прочитаємо
питання і подумаємо, як на нього відповісти багато
науково-фантастичних фільмів представляють темне
бачення майбутнього, оптиміст
чи песиміс  про майбутнє
людства подумайте, як ви бачите
майбутнє з технологіями, вони
безумовно змінять наш світ, але як
на краще чи на гірше, що ви
про це думаєте і чому це отримуєте?  більше
інше число,
нехай це буде десять запитувачів, коли ви
отримуєте свій продукт, чи читаєте ви
інструкцію з експлуатації чи ви просто розумієте
це, не читаючи нового телефону,
будь-який гаджет чи пристрій, як
ви знаєте, як з ним працювати
інструкція о, просто торкніться та
натисніть будь-яку кнопку, ви добре відповіли
і нехай буде ще одне запитання готове,
яке число, дозвольте мені вгадати, що якщо
воно п'ять, давайте прочитаємо питання, чи
технологія розвивається швидше, ніж
раніше.
ми живемо в епоху швидкого
розвитку технологій,
і щодня з'являється безліч нових гаджетів або
програм, і чи є у
вас страх, що ви заблукали, знаєте, що
він отримав, давайте зупинимося на цьому, коли ви
захочете відповісти на інші запитання або на  щонайменше, щоб
дізнатися, що це таке, ви можете зайти на
сайт, повний, знайти копію
технології та відповісти на всі запитання, так,
подивіться на ці фотографії,
скільки з них ви можете назвати десять
секунд
назви картинки
давайте перевіримо подивіться на слова і повторюємо
за мною
батареї ноутбук ноутбук планшет
планшет цифровий фотоапарат цифровий фотоапарат
супутникова навігація супутникова навігація супутниковий навігатор
супутниковий навігатор іноді можна
почути GPS-навігатор який встановлений навігаційний
мікрочіп мікрочіп пульт
дистанційного керування  USB-накопичувач
є містик отримати що це цифрова
камера для стрибання це пульт дистанційного керування,
який налаштований nav get set nav nice що
це планшет батареї мікрочіп мікрочіп
добре попрацював
, це кришка і USB-накопичувач добре,
добре, а тепер давайте зробимо це  шлях
без слів те саме завдання я вказую ви
кажете перевірити, наскільки добре ви запам'ятали
слова готовий іди
що це за цифрова камера гарні
батареї мікрочіп гарна робота
пульт дистанційного керування гарний комплект навігації супер планшет
зробив це ноутбук не ноутбук
ноутбук і USB-флешка
зараз дивовижний вигляд  на ці слова та
скажіть ці слова в алфавітному
порядку
чи пам’ятаєте ви ABC, дізнайтеся, який із них
буде першим, дозвольте мені допомогти вам
батареї правильно зробіть те ж саме без мене
дуже швидко давайте збережемо їх разом
батареї цифрова камера, але гусак наступний
ноутбук мікрочіп пульт дистанційного керування потім
переходить планшет із супутниковою навігацією та використовувати mystic
amazing давайте рухатися зараз давайте поговоримо про
те, для чого створені ці гаджети або пристрої
, ви побачите  зображення та
твердження, і вашим завданням буде читання
назви заяви на належному зображенні,
спочатку давайте разом назвемо зображення,
що це за мікрочіп, установіть навігацію, супер
пульт дистанційного керування,
наступне — планшет, ноутбук, використовуйте B
stick, смартфон, планшет, цифрова
камера та клавіатура  клавіатура для введення
готова постійна давайте граємо
ось малюнки, і це буде
речення, яке ви можете переглядати в мережі, але
немає порту USB, який пристрій вам
знадобиться для цього, але немає порту USB,
що це може бути,
ви можете переглядати  Інтернет, але тепер використовуйте порт B,
можливо, це ноутбук, тепер давайте
перевіримо планшет, добре попрацював, що правильна
відповідь, більше того, ви можете прочитати багато
шляхтичів один з цих wo  rds – це електронна програма для читання,
давайте перевіримо, що це добре наступним реченням.
Ви можете надсилати миттєві повідомлення, запитувати
та говорити зі своїми друзями
миттєві повідомлення дуже швидко це
смартфон, давайте перевіримо, чи правильно
ви можете керувати іншим пристроєм, наприклад,
телевізійним радіо або  Пристрій для запису аудіо/відео,
тут можна керувати
ключовим словом, тому для керування нам потрібен
пульт дистанційного керування, наступне
досить легко. Ви можете вводити з ним,
що знаходиться, де знаходиться наша клавіатура. О
, клавіатура, чи готові ви відповісти,
ви можете фотографувати та робити  відео, що
є цифровою камерою, ви
можете завантажувати файли, і є деякі
порти USB, які завантажують і використовують порти be, що
є портативним комп'ютером. Правильна відповідь наступне, ви
можете продовжувати працювати, всі ваші цифрові
фотографії тут зберігати всю велику кількість
інформації, яка  це три ліворуч
давайте перевіримо USB-накопичувач праворуч ви
два фотографії ліворуч ви можете визначити
швидкість свого розташування та місцевий час
, щоб зрозуміти, як визначити
швидкість розташування та місцевий час  Чи потрібен нам
для цього сайту дрімота, добре, чоп, і
навіщо їм останній, він створений
для програмної логіки та для пам’яті комп’ютера,
а це мікрочіп, іменник, який
ми зробили, подивіться на ці слова
в жовтому слові  банки давайте прочитаємо їх
разом встановіть повторюйте за мною установіть
правильний плагін аварії встановіть аварійний
плагін в іншу коробку дизайн
інструкції з дизайну інструкції та гаджет
революціонізував розроблений
експериментував номер чотири
процес інженера-дослідника та останній
лабораторія прогресу та тест тестування з цим
реченням  і доповніть пропуски
словами з поля. Зверніть увагу,
скільки пропусків ви бачите в реченні,
ну
і скільки слів три слова що
це означає
одне слово вийшло слово скажи 15 секунд читай
і закінчуй
[Музика]
готова
давайте перевіримо, що я щойно купив цю гру
для свого комп’ютера, і я хочу її встановити,
але я хвилююся, що мій
комп’ютер знову збій, а це номер два,
я не розумію  і як працює цей гаджет,
де інструкції до нього.
Ворота номер три, домашні комп'ютери
революціонізували світ, коли вони вперше
вийшли, і більшість з нас не може згадати,
яким було життя до того, як вони з'явилися,
шум
номер чотири зверніть увагу на розрив і
після нього  Ви можете побачити, про кого йдеться,
інженер, який працює
в моєму відділі, проводить дослідження щодо
нового типу технологій, зверніть увагу на
цю фразу робити дослідження не змушувати робити
дослідження повторювати за мною
робити дослідження робити дослідження робити дослідження
чогось хорошого  завдання номер п'ять,
вчені з лабораторії зрозуміли, що їм
потрібно було зробити інший тест, щоб знайти
відповідь на
запитання, давайте перейдемо далі
, щоб перевірити, наскільки добре ви вивчили
всі слова з уроку, готові
до вікторини  давайте пограємо, тож перше
питання якого розміру щось вам
знадобиться для камери, що мікрочіпує
батареї гаджетів, який розмір батарейок,
давайте перевіримо, чи ви наступний комплект
дрімає ноутбук  або використовуйте базові палички краще,
ніж планшети для обробки тексту, які
з них ноутбуки печалі або використання містики,
що ви думаєте, ноутбуки
давайте перевіримо тут, поруч слова, у
нас є процес встановлення та входу,
не вдалося гра, тому що його ноутбук вийшов з
ладу, тому він  не зміг встановити гру,
тому що ноутбук вийшов з ладу. Хороша
робота наступний протест прогрес і процес
багато чого було зроблено в
розвитку комп'ютерних технологій, що було
досягнуто значного прогресу отримати наступну
розробку експериментували або встановили Tony
з різними дизайнами для  веб-сайт
на своєму ноутбуці
Тоні добре експериментував наступне нове
встановлення плагіна який мій пароль мені
потрібно підключитися до Facebook зроблено добре
подумайте над питанням, чи подобається вам
користуватися новими гаджетами, чому б ні,
що ви відчуваєте щоразу, коли у вас
є  новий
гаджет ви схвильовані нервуєте хвилюєтеся
заінтриговані чому думаєте відповідь та
інше запитання чи є якісь
електронні пристрої, які ви хотіли
б мати, але у вас немає w  чи
вони новітні цифрові камери для смартфонів,
які б ви хотіли мати, щоб вони були
дійсними, і навіщо придумати
відповідні аргументи, щоб переконати
батьків сказати кілька нових слів, прочитати
слова камера навушники рух abhi
сигналізація система сигналізації
кондиціонування ноутбук мікрохвильова піч
мікрохвильова піч мікрохвильова піч будьте обережні
з підлогою телевізора та захисними дверцятами
захисні двері KITT давайте поглянемо
на завдання подивіться на список електронних
пристроїв у школі, можливо, вода їх
від одного найважливішого до
восьмого найменш важливого це питання
про  гаджети, які вам потрібні зараз, це
стосується вашої школи від
найважливішого до найменш важливого, знайдіть
хвилину, запишіть числа від одного до
восьми та напишіть слова поруч із
числами, пам’ятаючи про те,
наскільки важливими вони є бути в школі
п’ять секунд  на сьогоднішній день приготуйтеся
пояснити свій вибір, потратьте хвилину або близько того,
але перед тим, як ви це зробите, я думаю, вам
знадобиться кілька фраз, щоб пояснити  Оце ваша
думка, давайте подивимося на них, тож
давайте прочитаємо разом перше, наскільки
я знаю,
повторюйте за мною, наскільки я знаю,
ключ нерухомості тепер, наскільки вони знають, скажи
ще раз, наскільки вони знають, добре, я можу
помилятися  але я можу помилятися я можу
помилятися але емоції bangla-pesa я
можу помилятися але сатана англійські
мушкетери зараз, наскільки я знаю супер
ямазакі Малія ДІСА я можу помилятися
давайте рухатися далі
я абсолютно впевнений, що я
абсолютно впевнений  певний жіночий рід '
я абсолютно впевнений, що так буде знову
я абсолютно впевнений, що добре я
майже впевнений, що я майже впевнений,
що я впевнений, що єдина сім'я, я
впевнений, що зробила, як це сказати
англійською  не винний, наскільки вони
знають, супер наступне, деякі люди можуть
зі мною не погодитися, але ще раз деякі
люди можуть зі мною не погодитися, але вчитель
і останній без сумніву
позиція, тому без сумніву без
сумніву скажи ще раз
без сумніву  добре, давайте перевіримо, як
це сказати англійською bett  e, на awesome you
без сумніву добре, це ще не тут
усміхнутися, наскільки я знаю, мила
yamazaki mulatto я можу помилятися
кетчупом і тепер де вона
висловила вашу думку про
пріоритет необхідних пристроїв для школи,
використовуючи фрази, які вони зроблять вашим  мовлення
логічно структуроване та легко дотримуване
отримати це
більше подивіться на ці пристрої чи можете ви
назвати їх,
що це за ноутбук гарні навушники
камера планшет і телевізор добре
подивіться на запитання у завданні уявіть,
що ваша школа хоче придбати нове
обладнання для своїх  Медіа-центр вирішує,
який із них буде найкращим для учнів,
і пояснюйте свій вибір
фразами зі
скриньки з думкою, спершу подумайте, які пристрої потрібно
придбати, які пристрої дійсно
необхідні для вашої школи, а потім ми
готові представити їх, які ви пам’ятаєте
про  важливість використання цих фраз
отримати
[Музика],
без сумніву, дайте Дарліну наступне завдання, яке ваше домашнє
завдання цього разу буде
говорити, щоб  завдання провести опитування
серед вашої родини та друзів, щоб
дізнатися відповідь на запитання, чи могли б ви
володіти лише одним гаджетом, який був
би лише одним гаджетом, який би ви
вибрали, і чому
тоді ваші висновки можна змінити на
відповіді вашої родини та друзів  перетворити
їх на кругову діаграму, наприклад, моя діаграма виглядає
як піца з скибочками, наприклад, якщо
ви запитали ще сім людей плюс ви
отримали вісім відповідей, наприклад, для
всіх з восьми однакові відповіді, це
означає, що половина кругової діаграми"
половина  піца буде того самого кольору, і
тут ви напишете це слово, яке вони
відповідають правильно,
уявіть, що T з восьми дає іншу
відповідь, так само, як я робив без мікрохвильової печі,
це означає, що четверта або чверть
піци буде іншого кольору і
напишіть слово, без якого пристрою ми не можемо жити, чи
можете ви зрозуміти ідею, скажімо, кругова
діаграма, а фрагменти покажуть вам кількість
цих самих відповідей, коли ви намалюєте, ви
робите свою кругову діаграму готовою описати
її, і знову ви пам'ятаєте  r щодо нашої
домовленості, як тільки ви захочете
отримати відгук про своє завдання, ви
можете витримати це зробити їх хештег домашнє завдання 9
виконано, я буду більш ніж радий отримати ваші
відповіді та дати вам відгук,
дзвіночок наш урок закінчено
дякую  за участь і
до скорого побачення, до побачення
[Музика].